we should tell him the truth the latest
doctor strange in a multiverse of
manners trailer released before super
bowl confirmed that patrick steward will
appear in the upcoming film patrick is
best known for playing professor x in
the fox produced x-men movies and is
seemingly reprising his role in the
doctor strange sequel through not
directly shown in the trailer the
veteran actor can be heard saying we
should tell him the truth strange is
seen throughout the trailer in this
mysterious facility leading up to the
instance of patrick's introduction while
doctor strange is on his way to meet
professor x he has been escorted by a
group of ultron butts whispers of
patrick stewart's return have been
swollen for months so if marvel was
going to reveal one of these cameos
charles xavier does make a lot of sense
what will be interesting to see though
is how much professor x will be tied to
the plot of the film is this simply a
quick cameo or is he coming along for
the ride with strange wonder and miss
america yes it's only a second or two of
footage he included in the professor but
his line of we should tell him the truth
just make it seem that he will be key in
furthering the story so i was actually
quite surprised that they showed
professor x in this trailer i was
thinking they might have saved this
cameo for the movie but perhaps he'll
actually have a sizeable role in the
movie which we just spoke about before
either way is really exciting to get his
role confirmed in this film and i'm
really excited to see what they'll do
with his character in this film and this
just makes me think what other cameos or
characters from the x-men universe will
we see in this film tell me your
thoughts in the comment section below if
you haven't already please like and
subscribe and turn notifications on so
you don't miss future content thanks for
watching